this is what I don't quite understand
how it's an ideology
well it is it's a suite of beliefs right
the systemic racism racism is baked into
the system privilege seeks to preserve
itself all of those things
okay well you've mentioned that a few
times I'm trying not to go down that
rabbit hole but but this is a huge a
huge okay but no no but it's not a huge
hole but it's it's also a lot of
conservatives believe that too you know
just talked to Douglas Murray the other
day there's there's uh Douglas Mari was
in Ukraine he is for the United States I
mean again I'm trying to that's that's
to go I'm trying not to go down to the
Ukraine thing but you you have it it's
just like it's supposed cryptocurrency
too it's just like Chris
has some great stuff on that for why
that is it's it's it's a they're also
very pro-vaccine and toxicity it's a
toxin to work but all those things are
in the orbit of the ideology
and all of it in essence of mindless
adherence or
what do you mean like how is being at
war in Ukraine opposing cryptocurrencies
and being pro uh big pharmaceutical
companies in any way Associated I mean
in fact I would argue the the the being
in favor of massive multinational
corporations is actually it's
paradoxical it's kind of like joining
the military yeah assuming this this
Consciousness like if Joe Biden tells
you then you're gonna do it they've
accepted people that some people have
accepted whatever they say okay so so
two things one what Ronald Reagan said
in his famous debate there you go again
you're assuming and I don't mean that as
a as a slander on you but you're
assuming a kind of rationality that the
proponents of the ideology have that
they simply do not have oh I'm quite the
opposite I'm saying they quite literally
have no rationality and there is no
coherent ideology at all what we're
looking at is a sewer of refuse that has
been mashed together yeah and what's
happened is I think regular people who
are looking for answers seek experts who
are and they find academics who then
give them a very academic explanation
okay okay so let's talk about a sewer
that's been crammed together and
force-fed right who's doing the force
feeding the algorithms
okay again I'm not saying you're wrong
I'm saying I'm telling you in no
uncertain terms the data is utterly
overwhelming for this for the people
Force feeding them are people who have
gone through teacher training programs
colleges of Education their University
their University administrators we
released a a show Lyle Asher released a
show on my YouTube channel why colleges
are becoming Cults we know why this is
true and the the likelihood that two
ideologies that the same ideology could
be both promoted in K-12 and academic
institutions and be promoted by the
algorithm at the same time is virtually
zero so Jack Dorsey who pushed the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party
until 2014 who also lied before Congress
and hasn't been subject to perjury yet
go ahead go ahead pre uh the original
Twitter when it was created was the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party
when he created Twitter it was in in a
similar vein to the Ron Paul revolution
of Freedom libertarianism Etc and then
there was a shift now it's entirely
possible that the the explosion of data
points from we see from Lexus Lexus
Nexus in every country on the planet the
exact same time could be because a
globalist cabal got together sat around
a a table and said Implement order
wokeness our plan has come to fruition
and then they activated the device which
turned every country into a woke you
know disaster zone or it could be that
the Advent of cellular technology put a
phone in everyone's pocket and then we
gave everyone access to communication
devices which Amplified our social
biases okay creating two two things an
interesting thing in countries like Iran
and China that an inverse conversation
they went completely anti-woke but still
saw the emergence of the same language
okay let me ask you a question then
taking everything that you just said
what is the disconfirmation criteria for
that like what piece of evidence or
rationale or Reason would you have to
hear that that would throw that
speculation or hypothesis into question
the Lexus Nexus data that's been
repeated on multiple occasions was
incorrect
the data is falsified uh the the
tracking of this terminology and the
rise of this language was misinterpreted
and in fact has always been around
something like that you could see the
algorithmic code over the last 15 years
if you had like snapshots of the code on
a weekly database to see like was the
algorithm actually inviting this
discourse I spoke at universities after
Occupy Wall Street yeah I did not see
this I I what year was that this is 20
uh end of 2011 I was being invited to
speak at University into 2012 and 2013
and then yeah I don't think it came to
prominence it's also we have um it
didn't come to prominence and the
universities well well I'm just
literally just going to say it's also a
geographical phenomenon so for example
it's New York it's yeah well it's worse
on the coast it's worse in traditionally
blue places uh when I was at Occupy Wall
Street lokeness was just starting to
permeate into the leftist ideology and
it was confusing to a lot of people when
I went and spoken universities follow
occupy following Occupy Wall Street all
of the journalists were class all of the
professors were classically liberal they
were very much in that in that
classically liberal vein where I am
right now and you probably are and then
over the next few years I am especially
with what we saw with gamergate we saw
the expansion of wokeness which came
from the internet and from young people
into the universities and then what we
ended up seeing was a lot of people you
can see the effect with celebrities you
can see the effect with corporations
slowly start adopting what they think is
is prominent and I think they do it let
me I'll give you what you're looking for
let me I'll give you what you're looking
for read the algorithm let me ask you a
question let's say we had a pie chart
and I'm claiming that it's K-12 College
of Education College administrators
infused throughout the curriculum
diversity statements all of the stuff
that seek to both indoctrinate students
in an indoctrination Mill and perpetuate
the ideology let's say that you had two
of those and they're not competing and
you're going to fit them in a pie chart
what percentage of that of that pie
chart is algorithm and what percentage
of it is academic institutions so so
what do you mean you mean like right
it's responsible for the freaking
catastrophe responsible 100 algorithm
then our disagreement is far more
substantive than I thought yeah I so so
the issue is
when
I I think what's happening is people are
seeking answers as to what this ideology
is they're seeing specific examples of
it they're uh many people are looking at
the news in a very short-term
perspective and then they're following
experts who they believe are academics
uh I'm sorry academics who they believe
are experts on the subject matter and
who likely are in the specifics of say
you know critical race Theory and
critical theory but they're not actually
looking at the Hard data of the social
phenomenon that's occurred
and and the strange thing to me is like
as I often try to explain there's
hundreds of thousands of ideologies that
existed in universities 20 years ago and
sort of still do but they're being
pushed out all the pre-social media pre
uh these this wokeness did not exist at
all
at all good and so uh simply put when
Anheuser-Busch says
I don't want my content appearing next
to these things these things get removed
from social media yeah it's an
amplification machine that keeps
spinning up and recycling these
ideologies which keep changing name and
there's there I think the issue is
you know I'm on the ground at Occupy
Wall Street I'm on the ground at various
protests in La all across the country
I'm in Spain and I'm seeing similar
things and I'm seeing similar behaviors
that don't have a core ideological
function and then today I'm seeing
pro-vaccine stuff I'm seeing profoti
stuff I'm seeing Pro Biden stuff I'm
seeing vote blue no matter who always
use your corporeal
childpot GPT too and I'm seeing uh
Ukraine war stuff none of these things
fit your argument now it is true I think
that universities have become Mills of
wokeness but I think Within These Mills
it makes no sense that there's a rainbow
flag next to a Ukraine flag there is no
ideology that brings these things
together what does however is a social
media algorithm that says adhere to
Orthodoxy
okay or straight up the President
telling people to do it and they're so
afraid of Donald Trump that they're just
falling in love why are they even afraid
of Donald Trump because they're like
psychotics too poisoning the food supply
during the TV for four four hours a day
eight hours a day where in in these
theories these ideologies is Trump
derangement syndrome
uh so the the Trump derangement syndrome
as far as I know I'm sure someone's
written a paper about it but that's just
something that's people have used that
often often say conservatives have used
uh Sam Harris is an interesting thing
about Trump trump derangements well he's
Trump deranged
the dude is Sam Harris is clearly
unwilling to reflect upon himself he's a
perfect example of what he's complained
about with Islam he doesn't self-reple
reflect upon the fact that he's wrong at
all he doesn't look at any of the data
he just hates Donald Trump to the point
where he said he believed it was good to
cheat to win elections all right wanna
so here's my suggestion to you why don't
you have him on and have a conversation
with him oh yeah absolutely I mean
anytime so but but the point is Trump
derangement syndrome exists in the left
refers to it as Trump what do they call
Trump anxiety disorder and so you what
just to be clear for for people
listening by Trump derangement syndrome
you mean
when people become irrationally angry at
the thought of Donald Trump the
truth-telling around Donald Trump or
anything he does but I would also for
example when they said that the
terrorist was an austere scholar they
either anything he does is framed
negatively and any defense of him in any
factual stance like hey you know Trump
when he when he threw the fish with
Shinzo ABI into the koi pond yeah Shinzo
Abe actually did it first they say
you're a trump supporter they get
irrationally angry Sam Harris being a
good example he says that Sam Harris
believes subverting elections is a good
thing because Trump is that bad he said
Sam Harris actually said that if there
was legitimate evidence of Hunter Biden
sexually abusing children it would not
be as bad as Donald Trump running a
fraud University I heard that that is
now now where in leftist ideology does
that exist it doesn't what does is that
Sam Harris is beholden to Liberal social
Orthodoxy crafted by algorithms and he
doesn't want to break from it I'll tack
on part two of the definition of trump
derangement syndrome is that when people
are obsessively in love with Donald
Trump it's another form of derangement
the cult worship that kind of thing
blinded hearing people I agree with you
what people don't use the word to mean
that but you're so yeah okay so there's
so much to unpack in this so when people
are accused of trump derangement
syndrome they will give the response
that that is a a slur that people use
who whitewash
the fact that Donald Trump and I'm not
saying I'm well I I gotta hear this yeah
it's it's that that Donald Trump is an
enemy of democracy and he has subverted
the democracy and he would not leave
office uh allegedly and he's a traitor
and whatever else happens
well their their response is not that
this is an irrational hatred of Donald
Trump it's that this is a rational
hatred of Donald Trump but but we but
any objective and I mean this literally
yeah any objective person knows that it
is irrational when uh I mean Donald
Trump was impeached why because he made
a phone call uh to Ukraine asking about
Joe Biden withholding congressionally
approved Aid in exchange for a political
favor okay so
I agree with you I agree that but again
perhaps see difference of disability
simply put these people believe that
because social media algorithms fed them
false narratives and lies
now they say that uh every cell in our
body is completely changed within seven
years that means someone alive today
their entire I don't know if it's true
but well I just I'm just making a
nonsensical point but wives tale the
point is a person's entire being if
they've been following corporate news
since 2015 is comprised of life that
believes all of these psychotic lies
about Donald Trump yeah that that we
have debunked over and over and over
again and I don't think Trump's a saint
I don't think he's the greatest
president who's ever lived or anything
like that I think on foreign policy he's
the best I've seen in my lifetime I can
tell you all the things that I didn't
didn't like what you've done what he's
done I can say that I was wrong when I
took his side over Thomas Massey
and then you go and talk to somebody and
it's it's become a Trope stop making me
defend Trump was a Trope throughout 2016
2017 when the media would lie they
accused Donald Trump of being a traitor
and having served the Russians as he was
president and there are people I
remember that who still believe this
yeah now that's Trump derangements yeah
okay and that's well that sense I think
I think it's really important your point
is really important that
and and I think it's really important
when we make mistakes that we've had
about things in the past that we kind of
fess up to them that's why I fessed up
to you about the hunter Biden laptop and
we had fall for that so I did think I
did buy into a lot of that media
narrative that maybe what he seems
unnaturally close to Russia something's
going on they lied why
well I heard a lot of that there's a
tape it said I'm sure you've heard that
Russian ladies of the night yeah you
heard that drinking a lot of Beverages
and this is my point social media
algorithms we're feeding this content to
people because it got clicks so what we
saw was yeah I mean again Tim there's
I'm not disagreeing with it all right
this is a huge problem I I don't I'm not
disagreeing with you I don't know how to
get out of it so yeah which is why I
mentioned the my side bias which is
making it worse yeah I think that we get
out of it in a few ways I think people
who are aware of the issue
should have as many kids as possible I
know everyone points to me and ask me
where my kids are you know personal
issues but we'll talk but you know I'll
keep that private so I think people
should have as many kids as possible
that doesn't mean your kids will think
like you it there's no guarantee but the
there's also a combination of factors
one get out of cities we we you know we
see what's going on with with Riley
Gaines we see what's going on in Austin
with um Daniel Perry the lies the media
is pushing on this guy it's incredible
So Daniel Perry's got or get off social
media altogether like lucianov has been
saying or John height for kids young
girls liberal girls young women white
take your kids phones away yeah take
your oh no it's actually it's
interesting it's not YouTube it's not
it's strictly social media it's the
problem that height found yeah yeah your
kids should not be on social media so
like they shouldn't have phones I don't
think they should have something well
that's another thing there's no again
I'm not familiar with the data I haven't
looked into it but people who are
familiar with the data say it's not
watching YouTube it's not reading books
it's not texting it's strictly social
media I will clarify they have these
cell phones that can only make they can
receive phone calls and texts those are
totally fine in my opinion you know I
thought you guys were saying something
interesting about Trump derangement
syndrome you're saying that it's like an
irrational fear of this and you're
saying that it's considered a rational
yeah I'm saying that the people accused
of trump derangement syndrome will claim
that they don't it's not a syndrome it's
a that it's not irrational it's rational
I think that's for sure and I'm trying
to look up what does that even mean
what's rationality it's something that
you can claim based on a reason what's a
reason well something that you think is
right what's an Hedonism like it's it's
so subjective this this stuff but this
is I actually think that's a really good
point when we're trying to break down
why these people think they're rational
they think they have a reason for it the
reason I say that they are Trump
deranged is the emotional Vigor that
comes along with it you come to me and
you tell me that Donald Trump was an
evil Tyrant I'll say why do you think
that yeah I go to them and I say I think
Donald Trump was the greatest president
foreign policy they lose their minds
yeah okay there's something there's
something really profound to that right
there's something that
people who can't engage they just get EX
like anthropogenically warming right
like anthropogenic global warning
if you make an argument against it or if
you make it or no matter what your
argument is there are some people who
will say well what's your evidence and
there are other people who will lose
their minds and this is the point I'm
making ultimately about the modern left
and wokeness is that climate change
Trump derangement syndrome and Ukraine
uh fauci none of these things line up
with Academia but they are deranged on
all of these counts and equally
defensible on all of these counts what's
the best way to figure out if someone
should fear a president
I think
looking at history and uh figuring out
how you should fear president you look
at history you probably fear all of them
including Donald Trump
amen absolutely so you you don't think
that Trump presented maybe unique is too
strong of word you don't think that
Trump presented a an especially
dangerous threat to our democracy why do
you say our democracy well I mean the
United States as opposed to Canadian
demand Trump represented probably this
the the best effort we had at a Saving
Grace of America of the American
constitutional republic you mean the
whole clearing the Swamp Thing not
necessarily
um my view of trump is that he was more
like a bull in a china shop and that the
Ivory Tower has been constructed over
the past hundred years probably since
just before 1913. okay let me let me ask
you this question on a scale from one to
ten
we should fear Donald Trump how much and
and we should fear Biden how much Biden
well it's tough It's not so much Biden
himself but Biden for for all that's
around him I would put it at an eight or
a nine and Trump I'd put it a
six five or a six okay so so this is
really I want to say something
interesting so every time I've asked you
a question you've given me an answer and
I know that that must sound like well of
course I've given you an answer because
you've asked me a question that I
consider it reasonable maybe if I ask
you a question about your sex life you
wouldn't answer the question but maybe
he would or maybe he would I know I
wouldn't ask him so I wouldn't ask him
so it doesn't make a difference but
there is something also
I think it's an element of that Trump
derangement syndrome that you mentioned
that you may there's a kind of
excitability or a kind of anger in that
or a kind of like when you ask someone a
question they get upset that you ask
them the question absolutely or they
don't want the questions asked at all
and that I think is more of a concern of
the byproduct of what's happening to
people's Consciousness and how they
engage each other
right because they go on social media
and they are told this is what you must
be whether it's true or false this and I
wonder if it has it's a component of low
testosterone or just outside of that
argument agreeableness individuals who
fear being ostracized because of you
know humans survive by being in in
social groups and those who are more
willing to take risks to lead if it's
the right thing so leaders versus
followers the people who are more likely
to fall into the follower category are
like don't challenge the order I will
not have you get me ostracized yeah
whereas my view is kind of like
ostracize me I don't care I'll do fine
on my own so I have I don't have that
fear that these people probably do they
get angry because their brain
understands that what is being told to
them is likely true but if it's true it
means the social order they're they're
using to survive is wrong now they're
faced with the The evolutionary fear of
a risk to their lives yeah so that's the
question how do you help people
in the literature it's called build a
golden bridge like how do you help
people walk over who are awoke and I'm
thinking like you know now I'm thinking
the FBI is going to come for me when I
say red pills
it's already to my social credit score
terrible
um you know and how do you help people
and not create adversarial relationships
to say oh wow geez you know I thought
this and made
Anheuser-Busch we need that apology more
than anything right now we need that
apology we need to say to every single
person who is blindly following social
Orthodoxy you're on the wrong side of
History thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time